then store era at focus on tiara noble
prince Targaryen is shimmy satin
container do present a lil area Dupree
Noble on shimmy it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureate in
chemistry honorary professor jaggat
Debussy
[Applause]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies the laureates ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of professor Joachim
Franck which are Henderson and myself we
thank the Royal Swedish Academy of
Science and the Nobel foundation the
world is large very large my head is
small it's quite small it's impossible
to put the world in my head
nevertheless we try to make some kind of
representation in our body
if this representation deal with life
and living things it is called knowledge
if it deals with space and forces it is
called physics we are three Bauer
physicists namely three biologists
working with the spirit of physicist
chemistry is following the steps of
Democritus about and it deals about
atoms study how the atoms bring our law
together or not are not brought together
forming molecules or various complex
structures
we free have never been good chemists
nevertheless we obtain a Nobel Prize in
Chemistry is this an illustration of the
Peter Principle which let's think that
people reach their level of incompetence
or perhaps it is simply a beautiful
illustration of the unity of science
thank you
[Applause]